هناك العديد من الأشياء التي تحدث من
حولنا ولا يمكننا إدراكها ، لذا إذا كانت
لديك تقنية ، يمكنك الكشف عن هذه
الحقيقة والحصول على
تجربة أعمق للكوكب ، لدي زوجان من
الغرسات على قدمي متصلة
بجهاز قياس الزلازل عبر الإنترنت وفي كل مرة
هو زلزال
في أي مكان في كوكب الهجرة في
جسدي ، لذا من أجل مشاركة ما
أشعر به كأعمال فنية خارجية رائعة ، فأنا
راقص ومصمم رقص ، لذلك
أردت تجربة الحركة بطريقة أعمق
كلما حدث زلزال
أتحرك  وفقًا لسلطة الكثافة
، يشبه الأمر إلى حد ما دويتو بين
الأرض وتقديري لذاتي هو في الواقع
كارافا الوحش وأنا فقط
أفسر بيانات الجبن
الآن بعد أن
شعرت بسنوات الأرض التي أدركتها  أنني في الواقع
أردت الذهاب إلى الفضاء ، لذا فإن مشروعي الحالي
هو الشعور بالنشاط الزلزالي
للقمر وهذا سيسمح
لي في الواقع بأن أكون جسديًا على الأرض
وقدمي على القمر